hey and we're live welcome everybody
another episode rich the inspire
photographer helping him grow his
business rich welcome back man yeah glad
to be back so what's going on how can I
help what's the latest update last week
last time we talked about your
environment yeah sucking anything better
we're working on music I worked on I had
that worked on I've got pictures on the
goods on the walls got all that stuff
going on everywhere let's see the wall
again I want to see the wall what do you
have on there oh man now you want to
read all that stuff also I well some of
it i would like to tell me what I want
to know what inspires rich okay here let
me see if I can you see that do you see
that be the change honestly in the world
your godly going on there like it yeah
okay good everything is possible hero
believes I like to believe you know that
yeah so I got your belief thing
happening everywhere I'm like I get is
the fundamental anything and everything
well I believe I cream and you know how
to convince me did you miss me so tell
me what's what's going on that did that
help that environment change that
totally it helped those is a good first
step and then I had to put some
structures in place and also funny thing
that helped that I didn't you know I had
nothing to do with this was just
something I needed to do for my own
purposes yeah I gave up drinking coffee
tea having the odd beer or wine like
alkali gave up tea coffee alcohol
anything that affects my mind in any way
I gave all that up about three months
ago through four months ago or three
months or something like that and since
then unbeknownst to me I just was giving
that up just just so I could focus my
mind better but ever since I did that I
noticed that not only was my mind
focusing but my confidence was growing
up and my ability to be with whatever
mood or situation I mean was stronger so
far if I had to do some work at any feel
like doing some work too bad I was still
doing that work or if you know it's like
I found this new control over myself
ever since I let all that other stuff go
haha I self-medicate like everyone else
right so the confidence killer there huh
interesting alright cool so tell me
what's going on how it can help so y'all
since last time I started to fill my or
feed my youtube channel anyway did hold
on for consistently it's good i've been
keeping steady for one video a week for
the last part of know like two months i
think about that and and yet now at this
point I'm just want to know what's next
well too so now I've got the consistency
down to one video a week yeah what
what's the next logical step to kind of
get better yeah look at the notes from
last time it was that was that your
environment sucks it's not motivating
and you gotta stay consistent so i like
it i like i like the action taking man
it's good yeah okay so so i've seen i
think i've seen every video on your
channel look at the new one that you
sent or the same in live yet right um
it's um it's not unlisted but its life
ok but like I've seen all the ones that
have gone live on your chain drop
pedicure and i think i've commented on
them so good so a couple things um one
and this will come a lot of this comes
with practice but one getting more
comfortable still right like I think the
one we did together uh that then
entrepreneur picked up and now they want
to have you on their channel right like
Q yeah that's huge news that's great um
that one you were felt like the most
natural you do other one and that's
interesting to me because I found when I
was with other people I was more nervous
and not as much myself I found it easier
to be calm and myself when I was by
myself yeah where were yours like the
one we did you were that was the mo
you calm cool not nervous I think from
all the ones that you've done such
that's it's interesting but but so it's
doing more like as you do more as you
get more comfortable even now even the
ones you do now or better than the first
one that you did we're slowly getting
better and better better so like one is
just consistency like keep it up like
consistency is great but one month of
consistency is not consistency right
like you got a you got to keep it going
right three months four months six
months a year right you got to keep them
keep it coming up so it's great that you
started building that muscle you'd built
it into like I've you built into your
calendar to a regular schedule now that
it's because you're coming up with them
once a week do you feel now on certain
days and get rid of so I've got them out
once a week but I haven't scheduled it
properly to a specific time or date that
I'd do it I know I've been playing a lot
of catch-up as I was figuring stuff out
how I was gonna do it with cameras gonna
use all that stuff but now that I'm more
or less have it kind of figured out I'm
also starting to get into the hang of
doing multiple videos in one day
recording and then editing them all at
once so it's a lot easier for me so I at
first i was playing catch-up for the
first month just doing one video we can
barely making it yeah but now I'm like
two videos ahead so I want to get to a
place for 56 video goes ahead and then I
can maybe change it from one of week two
to a week nice oh yeah I'm liking that
so a couple pots there a couple thoughts
yeah i'm a maybe this works more for me
than then for you but something
experiment i'm a big believer in setting
the schedule and having something that
you regularly do on certain days and it
may fall off every now and then you have
a client shoe or whatever but if for
whatever reason you fall behind you'll
find that this is one of the things that
it's dropped right like oh I can't do it
this week because I gotta go go work on
this client treat or I gotta go pick up
my kids or I gotta do whatever right uh
so if you know that wednesday is your
shooting day and you protect it you're
much more likely to stay with it if
you're going to be doing more than a
video a week I
we try to switch up a theme so you have
your ask rich you've got your own like
people asking questions it's great I
probably wouldn't do to ask riches a
week I would try to find something else
to do on the second one if you're going
to do a second one Wow and then my other
thought about going to I wouldn't go too
far in advance because it can also
stifle your creativity like if you want
to try something like it's easy to get
locked into a habit of doing the same
thing because you're so far ahead if you
want to try something new or different
then you know it's not going to go on
your channel for another seven weeks
it's it becomes demotivate god I want to
try anything you end up just keep doing
the same thing over and over and over
and over again um so I would it's great
you've been consistent I would in order
to encourage you to be more consistent
and keep on that train to find the time
during your week whether it's monday
wednesday friday weekend something
something for shooting and something for
editing whether it's the same day half
days for each whatever it is because
you're doing both parts you you're still
doing the editing right yeah yeah so on
the video we did together I experimented
with it and editor see how it would go
so I'd like to at some point pass it all
on but right now I gotta do most of it
yeah i mean the editing the other thing
takes full take way more time than the
speaking I don't know what percentage is
that for you now but as you get better
you'll be able to just come on Cameron
banging out yeah it's going better good
man and then the editing still takes a
lot of time I mean you can set up for
its and stuff but the idea takes time so
that's how I want from one video week
two to one a day editor let me change my
business um Ahmed's asking in what was
your first week when you give up coffee
how was your first weeks are you have
head aches pains problems how long did
it take you to start to feel good
without giving up those things you know
funny thing I love coffee like I can
have like I buy my beans i take care of
them i freeze them i really take it i
have nice good coffee very strong too
looks super strong not have it every day
like one good strong
one a day or maybe two and I gave it up
like that no problem no headaches no
nothing it wasn't even a coffee thing
was more one of the major reasons I
wanted to give it up was because i was
using it as a crutch you know if I
wasn't really jazzed up or energized
okay go make a coffee you get your
energy or if you know if all of a sudden
you're in this wheel during that will
have a coffee and then I decided you
know if that I'm gonna generate my own
wounds whatever it is feeling I'm gonna
deal with it and then I'm gonna create
whatever it is I want to feel so why had
that as a motivator so whenever I had
the craving but it was no big deal it
was that was gone and I get a whole
bunch at once to because I'm like that I
had to give everything up at once that's
interesting you're very like on off kind
of guy man it was it just like you you
didn't want to do video at all and then
boom I'm doing video it's interesting
what's the topic about Adam it's a it's
a coaching call rich is a photographer
building a business around inspire and
once a month we hang out and help him
with his business so you've questions
comments before you can leave it in the
chapter on the side okay so back to you
making your youtube videos yeah I would
try to figure out a time in your
schedule you can do consistently and
ideally for going to go ahead of
schedule 1 ask rich and then one
something else do you have an idea what
that something else might be well the
something else could just be what I
started with which was just a tip around
photography video so I just got really
hunker down and you know do some
research or figure out what other tips
people are going to want to know about
and you just create those tip videos and
then see where it goes from there that
those were like the two easy ones to
start with and yeah there's more than I
want to do I just haven't haven't really
opened that up yet what about the
inspire stuff you're doing the fear
videos the inner yeah those ones do take
a lot of time to do so I have a bunch of
that I want to do in terms of not just
two interviews but also the master
so we've done together yeah could you
add those yeah could you split those up
so that you're not releasing like a full
interview but you're just doing one
question at a time kind of thing the
question that you find really inspiring
to do it in bite-size chunks yeah
totally totally because actually out of
each interview usually there's five or
six videos that come out of that like
one full-length one and then the
bite-sized pieces so I can totally do
that I've just uh yeah I gotta pick that
back up i have have an interview anyone
in a little while so so what if you did
11 rich tip ask rich kind of video a wii
and then one bit from one of your
interviews okay yeah a week okay yeah
that's that's gonna have like a four
week delay before I get the first
interview shot and edited so even if I
say yes to it now it won't be
implemented for at least a month sure I
mean the other thing you do is do an
interview over hang out do something
like hanging out yeah I mean that's what
I do um I have interviews I do it once a
month hanging out with Stephen Kelly
who's the CEO of sage it's a
multi-billion dollar accounting software
company and we we chat and help
entrepreneurs live and that's once a
month and then I'll take some of the
best clips for people who don't want to
watch a full hour is an hour long
interview each time ah one question that
might be three four or five minutes
every week so the best like four
questions four or five questions from
that session will turn into something
that just goes out on a Saturday
afternoon so it's the replay um so evil
is interview people through a hangout
which could probably a lot less work to
set up and travel and organize and all
that not let I stopped doing the other
stuff keep doing that but it could be an
option to make it a little more easier
yeah yeah I haven't even looked into how
to how to do what you're doing these
hangouts
well you're good you're on one already
so it's not that hard to be on the other
side a drug dog saying hi hey dread dog
I so okay so I mean I like those two
ideas right two videos a week one rich
expertise one inspires it it also means
you don't lose the inspire stuff you
don't lose the stuff that you're doing
and then it's like a shock to the
audience when they come and they see
this totally different series right so
it's good to have but um yeah cuz I
still want to do that tears I still I'm
still interested continue with it so
yeah then on going in terms of you
getting better what I would look at is a
a couple things one I know you're
playing around with the background yeah
the last two I think I've been funky
like psychedelic stuff happening behind
you yeah yeah I've been a bit like the
lot of experimentation whatever is going
on back there uh and it's cool i
continued it right like keep going
experience ki see what you can do to
make better I love you've added some
sound effects click on the last 1i so is
that you doing it for that's your editor
that's you me okay so I like it and I
like the tips I like what you're saying
I think the two things to improve our
one on the editing side it's good for
where you're at in terms of your career
as a youtuber I think if you compare you
to other youtubers who aren't your
channel size and your length it's it's
better it's way better but I think it's
not at the level that you could do and
not at the level that would show off
your work where somebody would say I
want to hire that guy to produce a video
for me right cuz I your stuff is held to
a higher standard because you're in the
business right I mean I could produce
something that's little lower quality or
whatever cuz i'm not i'm not a
professional photographer and
videographer right so like your stuff is
held up to
a different standard where if you want
people to to I think people should look
at your stuff and say wow even if the
content sucked and I'll give you an
example um the guy who shoots my videos
his name is jason n he he's a local
truant entrepreneur and he's done a
number of different projects with
different clients and all he does is the
editing and the and the videography he
shoots it like he films it and he edits
it and he's teamed up with a bunch of
people in on other projects and they've
just totally dropped the ball like the
people on his team have sucked royally
you know Jason's had the hard carry that
team like an insane madman right so you
know they've hired a director and a
producer and a storyteller like a
screenwriter and all of them sucked you
watch the video and the story sucks the
script sucks the actors suck everything
sucks but what Jason made is awesome
because he's using this camera and you
know the way he shot it and the editing
and he put it to in a way it matches the
music is insane it's really really
really good it's really high in
cinematography kind of stuff um and even
though everything else sucked in the
video right like the videos no messaging
with terrible actors no plaughter
storyline he still gets jobs from it and
he puts it on his real because he's the
videographer right he's like this is
what I can produce you put me on a team
with a good writer and a good produce
and a good director then we'll make it
even better and he's getting some really
nice some really nice gigs from it um
and so I think the same thing could
happen for you if I looked at your
videos and I said wow that's really good
like rich is okay like the points are
good he can get better you know but man
that's shot really nicely like I wonder
how he does that right um I think that
could really help drive business like
not just drive subscribers and views and
comments on your channel but like get
you customers who want to use where is
the room for that when you do like a
YouTube video or you're just talking to
the screen right just to the camera
there's is nothing there I mean my
background is if you look at any of my
actual work as a filmmaker yeah you know
it's it's pretty good it's pretty
amazing yeah i doing ET tube video it
seems to me like it's more about the
content than to look because when you're
just got a talking head with a white
backdrop how good is it gonna get well
that's where where I'm at that's what
I've been doing just talking head with
the backdrop so how do you make that
better you tell me like you're that
you're the you're the video guy right I
mean even if you look at mine so my old
videos I used to do white background you
can go back on the channel like a year
plus ago it was always white background
i filmed up myself to set up a camera um
now I've switched it up where I'm always
in a different setting like I might
start on my believe wall in them outside
and I'm somewhere else um the quality
looks way better than what I did you
know maybe it could still get better
maybe your critical i could find points
to make it better but you know as soon
as for example i got hired so Jason
comes and he comes in films this for me
right as soon as I started releasing
those videos people sort of comments
like man the quality just got upped on
your channel I always say wasn't the
quality of me it was a quality of the
footage and so I i look at your videos
and they're good but they're not like
that level where I'm where like if I
wanted to create a talking head video
for example I want to create a talking
head video I want a reference yours to
say this is how you should shoot it look
at the lighting this guy uses look at
the angles he's using look at the
Christmas of the picture I don't know
like a simple talking head picture would
they point to your video over my old
ones over somebody else's right I think
there's room to rise there to make it
that's Tony rooms riser I'm still kind
of doing it in a gypsy studio right I
don't really have a studio setup
point I'm just kind of playing with
different areas just settings I don't
even have a steady camera yet just kind
of playing different cameras rather than
going in you know I practice what I
preach rather than going and buying like
an expensive camera to these YouTube
videos I'm just using what i have and
seeing how they work and what's going to
be better the only thing that may be a
downside but at this point like I don't
care is that I'm doing it live I come
literally experimenting finding
everything out live and broadcasting it
so you can see all the horrible videos
and all the bad quality and all the
different you know one day it's white
background one day is this crazy
psychedelic stuff every day is different
and you know for now I'm okay with it
but I totally agree with you like just
today I was experimenting with a couple
new camera setups like check this about
if this isn't camera and this is the
camera as opposed to what i'm using
right now is a different camera some
continually playing with them and i
think where it's gonna go is obviously
quality is important to me racing my
background it was always like quality
was number one quality was king so all
my work looks like world world class
looks like hollywood style terms of my
video work like my music videos and
commercials but where it lacked was the
content like the quality was awesome but
the content sucks then it's worthless
yeah actually even in the kc nice that
video says the same thing like you can
have the best quality [ __ ] and if the
content is not there then it's garbage
but goes the other way if everything
looks like crap but the content is good
the story is good then you know and
there's a lot of great examples out
there like that so okay maybe I'm going
at it backwards right now I'm figuring
things out but I totally agree with you
and I'm getting my stuff together in
terms of the key remember names plus I
want to use my experience to share with
other people on YouTube to show them
that no even though i'm a pro i started
youtube just like you would with
whatever I had and I just kind of kept
upgrading cameras backgrounds figuring
out what it is that I need to make the
youtube channel look good and growing
and scaring that growth with these guys
and when I when I get better at videos
and I get more consistent I'll get a
little more elaborate and creative like
you
go outdoors shoot some more robust kind
of videos so I guess what I'm saying is
that I'm so focused on making the
content good yeah i'm experimenting with
the with the quality then quality's not
number one from you right now because
for me to get better quality just means
i have to invest a bunch of money and a
setup like I actually have to set up a
wall like a space with lighting that
lives there cuz you know to do that
every time you need to shoot to just
take up lights and set them up and break
them down just so much it just wouldn't
fit in my schedule would be able to do
it all that's why I'm kind of just doing
it as a hack job for now as I'm getting
everything better yeah my next time so
yeah i agree i think i mean i don't have
a studio right this is not a student do
you have this place that are permanently
in terms of what you do right now yeah
i'm in this wall i only use in two to
three videos a week i have 21 videos
that go live in my channel a week this
is in two or three of them right so like
i'm not even using this much now as it
gets winter you hungry sweater you know
you guys watching we're in toronto
canada it's getting cold I'll find the
beating inside a lot more but you just
go outside like everything just being
filmed outside so it's like you said
where's the light okay oh they're okay
film right no no no external lighting
you know talking about me who are you
not me but like yeah like what a beauty
all right like you have the I are ready
to be able to do it without having to do
yes with the lighting and everything
could be could be even better but you
can already make improvements and like
you're the guy i would ask and how did i
make improvements right you have the
answers already you just got to do it i
think i think you know i think you could
just I think you'd be able to get more
business that's all I'm saying you know
like but yeah as you work on your
messaging and that's do you work on
getting better on camera which is
important into casey's point and to your
point yes the quality will you know the
quality of the footage won't matter as
much of the quality of the messaging I
agree and I've said that a lot on my
channel I think the difference for you
is that this is
you're medium and like my film guy Jason
he's dealing with a crap story and crap
you know quality messaging everything
but people look at the quality of the
video and he gets jobs because of that
well and i think i would love the point
to your videos and say man i would love
I would love to sit down would like my
Jason guy my video guy and say that
Jason look at what rich is doing like
how do we get that like see other see
how good he looks and how do I do that
right like I'd love for your videos even
if your message is totally crap right
which it won't be because you're going
to give up it's already good you're
getting better at it but I'd love for
that to be something that people want to
share um yeah and again it's told it's
great for where you're at but I think
because your videographer it your whole
to help a different standard and I think
I could generate business right like
subscribers are great but you know come
mouths to feed this is to grow right
lives are change you want to hire an
editor you got to bring in some cash and
they'll make that happen I think you can
get some good jobs from it um got a few
questions coming in Adam is asking
Aladdin addin add an Eden ETA n addin
eden by Megan Eden Eden Eden all right
sorry bro you have to let us know how
you pronounce it like a mic any
questions it's in it's on the live
version we're in a different we run like
you and me that were broadcasting he's
asking what your social media channels
are so we can check with your work say
people are curious about your work when
you see a rich are you sending them know
i'm i'm gonna find it and and put it up
okay well while rich does that you
riches pop that in the chat and i'll pop
it into the Elector xenos writing in
Xena was a loyal subscriber I copy and
pasted the quote you know that what what
inspire meant to you you know yeah
paragraph well I put that in the
description me wrote I love the quote I
see in the description you've earned
yourself a new subscribers
simply because of that quote I haven't
watched any of your videos but i will
keep inspiring just wait I love it oh
they love your inspiring message man
okay guys all right into the chance you
can check it out how could I see the
live feed as well ah the separate link
that if you go to my youtube channel
you'll see you alive right now but you
have to you have to pause it cuz then
you're gonna hear us in delay ok goddamn
echo ok yeah yeah sign is nothing who's
rich rich is a inspire photographer who
I'm helping me coach once a month on the
channel you guys can ask questions get
some support and he's youtuber to just
posted his channel down there and jed
dogs talking about he says he makes
videos in his phone i start in his phone
in his car using his phone sweet yeah so
so yeah so that's one thanks to the
quality of the of the footage like not
you but the gear not even so much the
key like you could do a lot with God you
can do a lot with an iphone man I seen
some things on an iPhone the look
spectacular if you have the eye for
right I don't have the eye for like I
have a general sense but I can't make
something beautiful from that and maybe
by watching your videos I'll be able to
learn how to do it but like you should
be you can create something amazing that
thing you held out the camera with the
microphone man that's that's some that's
better gear than I call right look at
that thing you could do so little time
you can see this is like you dislike a
five-hundred-dollar setup and what I
used at your place was uh that was a
seven thousand dollar setup will be shot
with your place what I usually use it
and when I'm shooting my youtube videos
there's like a 500 and not it it's about
a four hundred dollars setup looks like
an old handycam why can't you use the
gear that you use at my place to film
yours yes this is trouble the really
high end gear requires a knowledgeable
hang so I can't actually shoot myself
because I need to focus with it too so I
need to be on both sides i had tried it
before and this is what happened i'd
send it up as beautiful as a gorgeous
shot set at all
and then I'm recording a whole bunch of
video then I go to play it back and I'm
out of focus because I set the focus
there like right here and then I guess
when I stood at the spark that I'm
marked I was right here and just that
few inches made the difference between
in focus not a focus actually if you
watch one of my first tip videos it's
slightly out of focus fighting but it
was just some good nose and do it again
that I just put it in life so let's get
look at something set up so i get a
cardboard cutout putting the spot i have
one if you want I have a I have anna and
elsa from frozen life-size like up to
here you're probably up here is like
rich size cardboard cutout that you can
put on the spot focus take it out hi I'm
rich right yeah you just need yeah
marking dude I did something similar i
had my wife stand in for me I focused
off on her and then I had her take off
and I stepped in to where she was and
I'm telling you it's a matter of inches
sometimes so that i don't use a handycam
it's an actual like film camera yeah so
okay but you have more complex and again
you're the man I don't know this but you
can change the depth of field so that
what's in focus and what's not in focus
is a range it's not like this specific
you go to hear right I'm talking about a
difference between one light set up and
like a five light setup it's like it you
know it may you may be able to say that
in one sentence but it actually takes
quite a bit of work to do what you're
talking about and a lot of
experimentation experiment for youtube
video but you see the thing is it's it
for me it has to be something that's
scalable and duplicatable so if i create
this really complex big setup that no
one can do even for me he takes an hour
to set up then what is now no that's not
something i could scale it's not
something I can do everywhere it's not
something I could teach other people to
do i wanted i want to get it I want to
dumb it down to such a level that
in very short short video in a very
short explanation I can explain to
somebody else to do what I'm doing to
the same quality that I'm doing it I
don't want to be this big fancy
filmmaker that makes kick ass videos but
no one else can do the same I want to
basically make it so that everyone can
do a very cookie cutter that's where I'm
at right now is it I get it I'm gonna
make it good i'm gonna make a good i
think we're gonna make it PS you talk
about keith is really like it she was
transferring kc nice not if i'm looking
at a blogger somebody who wants to do
vlogs I'm passed into him because I
think he's the best one that I've seen
yeah he's not working with any lighting
zero right like he's outdoors he's in
New York City he's in his car he's in
New Hampshire wherever with his you know
he has this have you seen his setup he's
just got this like yeah got his cameras
got this that spider thing that you hold
on to yeah this is how he walks around
and films himself right yeah the quality
looks great so the me nobody uses a
$1,500 camera and that spider guy that's
about a hundred bucks just that thing so
I mean that's no big deal i can go buy
it and use the same thing but who else
is going to do that right oh my guesses
so this is actually important this is
important kind of line in the sand you
figure out how you want to do things
because there's the rich that could be
teaching people how to get started from
scratch that you could do this on your
own that you don't need expensive your
and that people will never hire you for
projects right these are not clients for
you they're there they don't have budget
too high to spend 500 bucks on a camera
so they're not going to ever hire you
for a project yet or you can be the rich
who is creating amazing content that
looks awesome that will actually get
business for you to help drive your
company forward and bring on a team and
continue to build if you're always going
to be like the cheap guy who is just
showing how you could be like me then
you're not going to get the clients it's
a different business model right it
could be like i'm going to do the
mass model I'm going to be a big
youtuber and I'm going to hit millions
of people and teaching about photography
or you can also you can do some kind of
hybrid combination of here's what it
looks like on my iPhone like we did when
you came over right like usual looks
like on an Android still look great but
here's what it looks like on my seven
thousand dollar whatever camera right
yeah I just feel like you're missing a
huge opportunity to actually get clients
and to show what can be done to be an
inspiration for others by just
cheapening out and just showing like the
low and stuff okay that makes sense yeah
noted and I'm already in the process of
remedying it by upping the the quality
with this this is a very similar to
casey's a setup right here and now the
next thing for me is Casey's got a
gorgeous backdrop right his humongous
New York City office with all kinds of
stuff going on you know he's all over
the place he's at his house in New
Hampshire on the weekends is on the
train he like that's it not there I'm
not there yet I'm not that comfortable
yet to just be able to shoot myself
anywhere and everywhere I'm varying on
right now I'm getting back as i'm doing
it in the privacy of my own little
basement or office or whatever but as i
do it more and more i'll be able to have
that kind of the coup yawns to go
anywhere and shoot it unlike I don't do
that yeah you'll see big matter of time
the first video i did in public walking
down uh i was walking down the street
and I and I had to make sure there's
like nobody on the street res like look
both ways nobody on this okay okay i can
go in sir Thackeray yeah yeah the
process you get used to it yeah just
today I was practicing with this camera
for when I'm outdoors and I just want to
do like random stuff like I when I don't
have my equipment so this also shoots HD
its action earring my son's camera it's
like only three hundred bucks but it's
really great because it does this it
flips so you can actually do your own
kind of video and I saw Casey saying
that he also shot a lot of his first
videos on these cameras so today I
experiment with this outside myself so
that was already big step I don't even
like I'm waiting on it to come out in
the channel is exciting yeah alright
cool so yeah but that's the thing i
don't know what what to do is vehicle
what am i what other videos can i create
off the cuff like what would they be
about cuz i don't know if i want to be
the photo video guru online i'm just
experimenting with like kinda like what
you said just start experimenting and
you'll see what would you like what you
don't like so yeah I mean my
understanding of you creating the
channel was you wanted to teach people
but also get business from it like you
wanted to use it not just as a fun thing
to do but also that would help drive
revenue for your company right I maybe
I'm wrong maybe I didn't understand that
problem why not initially the first few
videos I made with tip videos i made
that with my clients in mind I'm like
okay what would potential clients be
have concerns about that i can answer
right here so how did Stan how do you
prepare for a shoot what to wear like so
I made those tips videos for potential
clients so that I could share that with
them and I know the ask rich just came
out from a few people ask me some
questions but so that was kind of like
the reason I did it ultimately I don't
even know how this channel will lead to
the photo video work really small just a
tool for self-expression for me right
now and a personal growth tool right now
that's kind of how I see it well so
that's gonna it's interesting because
that's going to limit you write like if
you don't see how that's going to
generate business for you then it never
will right how do I make that lift from
that context is understanding that i'm
putting something out that people are
going to want to talk about that people
are going to want to share right people
see Jason's video they share it they
hire a new mom deals people see Casey's
they share it they hire him to make
videos for them right I want to look at
your video love it so much that I want
to share and say the next time I'm
making a video or I'm doing a photo
shoot I want to hire rich if he's
anywhere close to me I want to hire him
or maybe I'm going to fly him in like
Jason just Jason this guy i find him on
kijiji right like just like kijiji is
like craigslist for you Americans
watching out on his kijiji in the US I
don't know anyway last Google all right
Craigslist anyway uh he's quoting a
company saw his terrible video with no
story terrible actors all that crap
sighs video and now wants to he's
quoting forty thousand dollars on a
project to go to LA for three months for
single guy like no team just him
shooting take his gear editing 40k for
three months because they made he made
this awesome video that if you look at
you'll say from a cinematic point of
view that looks really pleasing to the
eye so like when I look at your stuff I
don't get that right if I'm like the
hobbyist guy who wants to make my own
videos become a youtuber take my own
pictures great works but if I'm like I
don't look at the eye and say man that
guy is sick I got to hire him for my
shots right if we were like that then I
would want to refer you and how are you
to come on do my projects for me but
that's not the type of client you're
going to get now you know you might be
able to build it up to get like speaking
engagements at conferences to talk about
cheap ways to do video or how to do it
yourself kind of stuff but it's not the
big client big budget you know flying
rich in to help me out with these
projects but like if you don't get that
if you don't feel that then you're never
going to make it right like if you're
not trying to make something high-end
quality that will get you clients then
you're never going to do it if you don't
see the connection um yeah I'm actually
out now I get when you're when you talk
about where you're coming from totally
makes sense cool um a bunch of questions
coming in and oh we're kind of over on
the time but kamal is asking how to get
people rich how do you get people to
take me seriously when he's 14 years old
what do you think I advise foreigner I
think don't even worry about it just
make the videos with whatever it is you
want to make them about and put them out
there and if the content is serious and
worthy being taken seriously they'll
take you seriously I think it's you know
content is king really
think the biggest thing for me I found
beat I was that young entrepreneur I was
19 and I was telling the guys three
times my age and feeling like why would
they talk to me i'm 19 these guys have
phd's their professors you know they've
done well I don't have a background like
the scientists I'm gonna sell this
scientific software to scientists when
I'm not a scientist uh it starts with
taking yourself seriously right like I
am good at what I do I can add value to
the world and I believe that to my core
right if you don't actually believe it
there's no way you're going to convince
somebody else right members story about
Nelson Mandela who went into prison when
it was jailed uh and he refused to be
called anything besides mr. Mandela he
wouldn't you just refute he commanded
respect right this is a prisoner here's
a prisoner duties if he's in jail and
they had to call him mr. Mandela to get
anything done and so like you got a
command respect if you provide value
people will listen to you and they'll
get a sense quick look even walking into
the room right are you like this are you
confident are you hi are you the lion
are you about to take on the world are
you like oh I'm like I'm this
fourteen-year-old kid and I don't you
know please give me a deal right like
already already you set the tone for
what's going to happen that day right so
it starts with you taking yourself
seriously yeah that's a big like mental
twist that took me a while to figure out
when you get your head around that
unstoppable man unstoppable well sounds
pretty powerful but how do you have
access to that how you have access to
what Ted to making that paradigm shift
uh it's it's fact to like everything
we've been talking on the past calls
right the environment that you have
around you your your belief system you
know what do you consume on a daily
basis that makes you want to be
something bigger than yourself and
believe that you can because all of us
we have these moments of boldness right
you have a day when you like wake up at
two in the morning Oh
got this great idea is gonna be amazing
and then where does it go like you wake
up the next day and is gone or right
you've killed yourself like it wasn't
that the idea sucks now he's just you
don't believe in it anymore because it
was too bold and made you step out too
far and then you're going to retreat
back so it's consistently having things
in your environment that stretch you and
force you to go out and do something
bigger like you want video man you last
year refuse to do any video like known
the guy behind the camera my friends on
Facebook you know will laugh at me
whatever right like you were in this
shell that you refuse to come out of no
matter how much I like rich man come on
you got this right whatever you know
your wife was supporting you right and
then finally like I forced you on camera
and this now opened up your shell and
now it's now now for you being in front
of a camera at your home is no big deal
like you're used to it you're getting
used to we're doing our hangouts you're
fine you're being open and honest now
the next step is like going out and
doing it in public or in the backyard or
like I get it I was there right there's
still times when I feel uncomfortable
than there is like any new situation
you're going to get in there but um what
always helps me is understanding that
hey I'm good at what I do I can provide
value to these people that I'm going to
work with and once I acknowledge that
and believe that the rest takes care of
itself like you've set yourself up for
failure before you even walk in that
room because you don't have the
confidence in yourself Zeno's writing so
Evan what you're saying is you gotta
believe you got at Z now you got it um
cool man we went on a bunch of tangents
but I'm liking it I'm excited um so so I
mean we're going to look at ideally
doing two videos a week one tip question
a tipper question like if you have a
question to question if you know of a
question can do a tip riches advice
whatever I think just get as you get
more practice you'll get better you know
your delivery will get better already
you're getting more confident I think
the biggest thing for you is just being
the bull because you killed it on the
video on my channel and it videos on
your channel we're okay and are starting
to get better so like you got it with
practice you'll get to the point where
you were when you came over to my place
and then you like you'll get beyond as
you do more you'll just you'll keep
growing so consistently every week and
then looking at making a little bit
higher quality so i look at it and like
man I gotta hire that guy to come do my
interviews yeah sounds good yeah I'm on
it good i right man yeah uh cool man so
bunch of comments thank you guys so much
for watching you could check which out
he sent the link or I added the link
riches now involved with a chat and
that's it have a great month man I'll
talk to you soon thank you everything
have a great one okay bye guys